auch hier eine messerstecherei mit
schweren folgen in essen sind wieder
einmal rivalisierende clans aufeinander
losgegangen dabei wurde ein 30 jähriger
durch einen messerstich schwer am hals
verletzt und musste ins krankenhaus
vor dem café in essen altendorf liegen
stühle tische tassen teller der streit
zwischen zwei arabischen familien clans
angeblich der als sein clan und der hass
an klar war offenbar eskaliert mehrere
hundert menschen waren an dieser
massenschlägerei beteiligt und neben dem
opfer der messerattacke wurde mindestens
wurden mindestens zwei weitere menschen
verletzt einer davon ein 30-jähriger
wurde bereits wegen eines raubdelikts
polizeilich gesucht und dann
festgenommen und wieder einmal stellt
sich die frage wann kriegt die politik
dieses kleine problem endlich in den
offenbar hat das großaufgebot der
polizei gestern abend weitere
ausschreitungen in essen nach verhindert
zu der erwarteten massenschlägerei waren
sogar extra menschen aus berlin
angereist und zwischenzeitlich ist auch
ein instagram post aufgetaucht der die
ganze sache herunter spielt und wie ein
ganzes völlig normales getan unter
klaren kriminellen erscheinen das schon
wieder rein ja unter der überschrift
salam salam aleikum schreibt der
wortführer zwischen mir und madsen gab
es ein riesen großes missverständnis und
wir haben jetzt alles wie richtige
männer geklärt möglich jeder seine wege
mit frieden gehen aleikum salam der
worte eines mannes der offenbar ein sehr
spezielles männlichkeits verständnis wir
sprechen über die hintergründe dieser
massenschlägereien uns zugeschaltet ist
bild chefreporter frank schneider
schönen guten tag frank man fragt sich
worum ging es überhaupt bei dieser
schlägerei wie konnte die zustande
kommen
die polizei weiß es noch nicht genau am
ende ist es immer ähnlich es geht immer
um gegenseitige beleidigungen und
provokationen gar über social media und
das wird dann später als missverständnis
mehr oder weniger deklariert wir haben's
ja gerade gelesen diesen prost und das
ist das verrückte daran diese person
mein einfach etwas zu klären die
richtige männer sind die szenen die wir
jetzt sehen dass man mit tischen mit
stühlen mit messer mit stangen mit mit
geschirr aufeinander los geht sich
gegenseitig schwer drei personen sind ja
bei dieser auseinandersetzung in
krankenhäuser gekommen die polizei geht
aber davon aus dass es mehr verletzte
gibt die sich eben nur nicht melden weil
ja dann auch klar ist dass an dieser
auseinandersetzung beteiligt waren und
das ist ein phänomen das war über viele
jahre schon beobachten dass während der
kroner zeit und insbesondere
nordrhein-westfalen durch die strikte
verfolgung strategie des
innenministeriums etwas eingedämmt wurde
auch gerade die essener polizei ist er
führend bei der clan bekämpfung und
jetzt haben wir plötzlich wieder diese
szenen und ihr habt gerade schon erwähnt
gestern abend drohten eine erneute
auseinandersetzung die da sollten
mehrere hundert aufeinander losgehen und
es waren sogar personen aus berlin
angereist die polizisten aus ganz
nordrhein-westfalen polizisten
zusammengezogen alle hundeführer dies
hier nordrhein westfalen gibt waren
wirklich in essen und das sind zustände
die er so eigentlich eben nicht mehr
haben wollen frank es werden menschen
schwer verletzt es werden sogar menschen
getötet dadurch und das alles obwohl es
auch zum teil wirklich vorankündigungen
gibt wie auch hier in diesem fall bei
instagram wird dann was gepostet und man
hat das gefühl warum kriegt der
rechtsstaat das nicht in den griff warum
kann sowas nicht verhindert werden
in dem fall muss man sagen gab es vorher
keine ankündigung dieser post stammt ja
von der also nach der auseinandersetzung
das hat der arrogante partie wie er sich
selber nennt hier in essen hat das dann
erst gepostet nachdem es zu dieser
auseinandersetzung kam und offenbar ein
wenig ruhe reinzubringen insbesondere
weil nach ansicht der polizei eher so
ein bisschen in der unterzahl ist bei
dieser auseinandersetzung denn er hat
sich mit dem als einen plan angelegt und
die sind natürlich sehr groß das ist
hier nordrhein westfalen gilt abstand
der größte klar wir kennen doch alle
mahmud als zahlen das war der pate von
berlin der vom halben jahr zwangsweise
ausreisen musste oder seiner 20
abschiebung
vorweggenommen hat und das ist hier
ebenso das häufig diese ganzen ja kanäle
die die herrschaft nutzen es geht hier
ja um madsen haben wir darin gelesen
madsen ist ein musiklabel eine
musikverleger von von gangsta rappern in
köln und da gibt es dann offenbar
auseinandersetzung auf kanälen die
teilweise polizei schlicht nicht
mitbekommen und man muss fairerweise
sagen es gab zuletzt diese
auseinandersetzung nicht es gab in
duisburg diese schießerei zwischen
rappern und rockern aber eigentlich war
ein essen in den letzten zwei jahren ist
deutlich ruhiger geworden das scheint
sich jetzt gerade zu drehen und die
polizei große befürchtungen es ist nicht
die letzte auseinandersetzung bleibt
sagt unser chefreporter frank schneider
vielen herzlichen dank dir für die
informationen